[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen zu den
Nachrichten viel Fußball gibt es gleich
von Norbert Lehmann
ein Machtwort und die Folgen die
kanzlerentscheidung für längere
AKW-Laufzeiten stößt in der Ampel auf
Zustimmung die Union übt scharfe Kritik
Streiks Leben in Frankreich der
Arbeitskampf für höhere Löhne trifft
jetzt auch Bahnverkehr und Schulen an
den Tankstellen wird der Sprit knapp
Inflation sorgen und royaler Glanz
Spaniens Königspaar öffnet die
Frankfurter Buchmesse große
Preissteigerung machen den Verlagen zu
schaffen
[Musik]
nachdem der Kanzler bestimmt hat alle
drei Atomkraftwerke bis Mitte April
nächsten Jahres in Betrieb zu lassen
ordnen sich sowohl die FDP als auch die
Grünen dieser Entscheidung unter aus der
Opposition kommt dagegen Kritik morgen
wird sich möglicherweise das
Bundeskabinett mit dem Gesetzentwurf
beschäftigen danach muss das ganze noch
durch den Bundestag und Bundesrat Thomas
Reichert
der Tag nach seinem Machtwort ist der
für ein erklärungswort Olaf Scholz hat
lange gewartet mit seiner Entscheidung
heute will er noch mal Klarheit schaffen
hofft einen lähmenden Streit in der
Koalition zu beenden
ab 15 April ist mit den Atomkraftwerken
in Deutschland Schluss und deshalb wird
es auch keine neuen Brennelemente mir
geben die irgendwie für deutsche
Kraftwerke hergestellt werden keine
neuen Brennelemente und ein festes
Enddatum für Atomkraft Scholz kommt
damit den Grünen entgegen dafür müssen
die schlucken das nicht nur zwei
Süddeutsche AKW weiter bereit stehen
sondern drei inklusive Emsland bis zum
Frühjahr weiterlaufen einige finden das
schwer hinnehmbar die Mehrheit aber wird
wohl damit leben können wir werden
empfehlen dass wir dem Vorschlag folgen
auch wenn die fachliche Notwendigkeit
für das AKW Emsland aus unserer Sicht
nicht plausibel ableitbar ist die FDP
war gestern besonders schnell darin dem
Kanzler Machtwort zuzustimmen eigentlich
wollten die Liberalen Laufzeiten bis
2024 und neue Brennstäbe jetzt zeigen
sie sogar Verständnis für die Grünen
die Grünen kommen natürlich aus der Anti
akw-bewegung deswegen habe ich im
Grundsatz für die Haltung Verständnis
und im übrigen wird Deutschland nicht in
die Kernspaltung wieder einsteigen
sondern es geht um eine akute
Krisenbewältigung die Union sieht beide
FDP und Grüne als Verlierer sie glaubt
dass der Kompromiss die Energiekrise
nicht löse das Machtwort des
Bundeskanzlers ist der Beleg der
Ohnmacht der Ampel diese Entscheidung
die getroffen worden ist sie gefährdet
die Energiesicherheit in Deutschland der
Gesetzentwurf für den befristeten
Weiterbetrieb der drei AKW soll schon
morgen im Kabinett beraten werden Ende
November könnte das Parlament darüber
abstimmen
für die Betroffenen Stromkonzerne
bedeutet die Entscheidung
Planungssicherheit und dass sie den
Weiterbetrieb der Atomkraftwerke
organisieren müssen
für das württembergische Neckarwestheim
2 hält der Betreiber das für
grundsätzlich machbar in Bayern muss Isa
zwei gewartet werden und wird dazu Ende
der Woche heruntergefahren dass das AKW
Emsland weiterläuft war ja zunächst
nicht geplant über die neue Situation in
Niedersachsen berichtet Peter Kunz
Gnadenbrot vom Kanzler für den alten
Meiler im streckbetrieb kann das
Kernkraftwerk Emsland zur
Versorgungssicherheit von rund einer
Million Haushalten beitragen für die
zuständige Landesregierung fehlt dennoch
der Wumms weil die Brennstäbe heute
schon so gut wie ausgebrannt sind da wir
jetzt schon davon ausgehen dass ab
November nur noch 80% Leistung erzeugt
wird dann werden auch
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen durchgeführt
werden müssen das ist die Voraussetzung
dass dann und es wird eine Zeit lang
dauern überhaupt eine Genehmigung
erteilt wird dass das Kraftwerk wieder
im Betrieb geht die vorhandenen
Brennstäbe müssen neu konfiguriert neu
ausgerichtet werden gut drei Wochen wird
Emsland also ab Januar wohl vom gehen
der Sicherheit geschuldet wie viel
Laufzeit bleibt dann noch netto nach dem
lauten basta aus Berlin wenn man das mal
ausrechnet ab heute dann werden wir
vielleicht in Summe bei 60 oder 65 Tagen
vollzeitleistung sein unterm Strich
haben wir nicht viel davon höchstens
Beruhigungen in der großen Politik und
mit Emsland an Bord vielleicht auch ein
besseres Gefühl vor dem Winter wenn es
sehr kalt wird und ihren hohen Bedarf
haben dann haben ja die Netzbetreiber
ausgerechnet dann würden die
Kernkraftwerke sehr helfen beim warben
Winter und alle französischen
Kernkraftwerke im Netz gibt es in Europa
wahrscheinlich genug Strom aber das
heute vorherzusagen ist natürlich ganz
schwierig auch kleinste Reserven in den
kommenden Monaten sicherstellen auf
diesem kleinen Nenner soll Emsland
weiterlaufen mit endgültigem
atomausstiegsdatum 15 April 2023 damit
die Ampel dann tatsächlich auf Grün
schalten kann für Strom aus erneuerbaren
Energien
wie können die Energiepreise gedrückt
werden dazu hatte EU-Kommission heute
Vorschläge gemacht unter anderem sollen
die Mitgliedstaaten künftig gemeinsam
Gas einkaufen können zudem sollen mit
fast 40 Milliarden Euro aus dem
Gemeinschaftshaushalt Unternehmen und
bürger:innen entlastet werden am
Donnerstag und Freitag befassen sich die
Staats- und regierungschefinnen und
Chefs beim EU-Gipfel mit den
vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen
im Ukraine Krieg greift das russische
militärverstärkt die kritische
Infrastruktur wie das Stromnetz an als
Folge seien heute mehr als 1100 Orte
ohne Strom so die staatlichen
Notfalldienste der Ukraine was das für
die betroffenen Menschen bedeutet
berichtet Alexandra Vacano
Anton serbrokow bereitet das Essen vor
für seine Mutter und sich draußen in
seiner provisorischen Küche die
Situation ist so kein Strom kein Wasser
kein Gas und ist kalt sie können sehen
dass wir Feuer machen
kein Strom nicht nur in der Region rakev
auch in schitomir westlich von Kiew nach
russischen Angriffen heute früh
heute um halb neun hat der Feind die
energieinfrastrukturanlage des Gebiets
schitomiert heimtückisch beschossen
derzeit sind 11 Siedlungen in der Region
vorübergehend ohne Strom selbst in der
Hauptstadt rosa morgen wieder Angriffe
gab sei teilweise Strom und Wasser
ausgefallen Attacken auch auf diese
Energieanlage hier in niebro ukraines
Präsident selensky twittert seit dem 10
oktober wurden 30 Prozent der
ukrainischen Kraftwerke zerstört was zu
massiven Stromausfällen im ganzen Land
geführt hat
derweil gehen die Angriffe wie hier auf
mikolajew weiter mit Raketen und Drohnen
wir haben schon den ganzen Kriegsverlauf
über russische Angriffe auf zivile
Wohnhäuser auf zivile Infrastrukturen
auch auf Energiesysteme gesehen neu ist
aber die Art und Weise und auch die
Brutalität das ist offener Terror
gegenüber der Zivilbevölkerung man wird
also versuchen das zivile Leben damit
zum Zusammenbruch zu bekommen kein Strom
kein Wasser keine Heizung wie hier bei
hakif darauf müsse sich jetzt das ganze
Land vorbereiten warnt die ukrainische
Regierung
der Chef der wichtigsten deutschen
cyber-sicherheitsbehörde muss gehen
erfolgt steht noch nicht fest
Innenministerin Phaser hat der Arne
Schönbohm den Präsidenten des
Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der
Informationstechnik kurz BSE von seinen
Aufgaben in bunten und zwar mit
sofortiger Wirkung Hintergrund sind
Vorwürfe das schönboom Kontakte zu einem
umstrittenen Verein mit angeblichen
Verbindung zur russischen
Geheimdienstkreisen hatte dies wurde
durch das ZDF-Magazin Royal bekannt
immer weiter steigende Preise da wird
der Ruf nach höheren Gehältern immer
lauter für die mehr als eine halbe
Million Beschäftigten in der deutschen
Chemie-Branche gibt es jetzt ein
Tarifabschluss zu Beginn des nächsten
und zu Beginn des übernächsten Jahres
steigen die Löhne um jeweils
3,25%. hinzu kommen zwei steuerfreie
Sonderzahlungen von insgesamt 3000 Euro
auch in Frankreich werden angesichts der
Inflation höhere Gehälter gefordert
heute findet daher ein Generalstreik
statt ein Auslöser die Regierung hat
bereits mehrfach streikende Beschäftigte
der ölrefnerin zur Arbeit verpflichtet
da der Sprit an den Tankstellen knapp
geworden ist die Gewerkschaften fordern
dagegen von der Regierung das
Streikrecht zu respektieren und wollen
mehr lohnen anna wassberg hat die
Tankstelle noch was oder ist hier auch
der Sprit leer seit drei Wochen sorgt
der Streik an Frankreichs raffinerin für
lange Schlangen ein wütender
Arbeitskampf der andere verzweifeln
lässt
für die Forderung habe ich schon
Verständnis aber nicht dafür dass sie
Menschen behindern die nichts damit zu
tun haben
heute konnte ich nicht mal ins Büro soll
ich nicht genug Benzin habe die
Streikenden fordern eine Gehaltserhöhung
von zehn Prozent auch um Inflation und
gestiegene Lebenshaltungskosten
auszugleichen während die
Energiekonzerne Rekordgewinne einfahren
die haben jetzt Angebote macht aber
nicht alle stimmen zu und der Regierung
reichts
was wir jetzt brauchen ist
Entschlossenheit Autorität und
Normalität wenn sich die Mehrheit in den
laufenden Verhandlungen für ein Angebot
entschieden hat dann muss das akzeptiert
werden das nennt man Demokratie die
Gewerkschaften machen weiter Druck und
haben zum Generalstreik aufgerufen
landesweit und branchenübergreifend
es ist nötig die raffinäre zu
unterstützen denn wir haben alle den
gleichen Kampf um Löhne
auf der Straße macht sich allgemeine Wut
breit gegen die Politik die
Gewerkschaften beraten jetzt ob und wie
sie den Streik weiterführen für viele
Franzosen heißt das weiter warten an den
Tankstellen
immer aggressiver beansprucht die
Volksrepublik China Taiwan für sich beim
Parteitag der Kommunisten der zurzeit
stattfindet drohte Chinas Staatschef
erneut mit militärischer Gewalt nicht
nur geopolitisch auch wirtschaftlich
hätte das massive Folgen weltweit denn
taiwan ist die Nummer eins nicht Chip
Industrie und Chips sind der
Schmierstoff der globalen Wirtschaft aus
Taiwan Normen und hatte
es ist der Stoff der die moderne Welt in
Bewegung hält Halbleiter die kleinste
Chips zu größten Leistungen befähigen
die Technologieführerschaft in Quantität
und Qualität hat Taiwan 60% aller Chips
werden hier produziert 90% der
leistungsfähigsten ein Schutzschild aus
Silizium gegen die Bedrohung durch China
das beruhigt manche nicht alle
die Welt braucht unsere
Halbleiterindustrie und deshalb muss uns
die Welt auch beschützen
früher habe ich mir nicht so viele
Sorgen gemacht jetzt schon unser
Verhältnis zu China wird immer
angespannter und hi Jim Ping ist sehr
gefährlich sehr ambitioniert
die deutsche Firma merk produziert in
Taiwan Halbleitermaterialien will in den
kommenden Jahren weitere 500 Millionen
Euro investieren ein wichtiger Markt der
Wachstum verspricht den Friedenszeiten
jedenfalls ein Krieg mit China würde
alles ändern dann würden weltweit
erstmal sehr sehr viele Halbleiter
wegfallen und das würde natürlich
erstmal zum Teil Zusammenbruch der
Wirtschaft führen dadurch dass einfach
die Halbleiter überall gebraucht werden
Automobilindustrie Medizintechnik im
Haushalt
Verbraucherelektronik überall brauchen
wir Halbleiter es gibt derzeit wohl kaum
ein globaleres Produkt keines mit mehr
Zugkraft wirtschaftlich und politisch
keine Frage Taiwans Chip Industrie ist
ein richtiges Pfund jede kleine Störung
der Produktion wirkt erhebliche Risiken
für die ganze Welt aber reicht diese
Erkenntnis aus zum Schutze für Taiwan
sich allein darauf zu verlassen wäre
reichlich gewagt
in Nigeria kämpfen die Menschen weiter
gegen die schwersten Überschwemmungen
seit Jahrzehnten es droht eine
Hungersnot nach Angaben der Regierung
wurden mehr als 400.000 Hektar
Ackerfläche zerstört in dem
westafrikanischen Land stehen noch immer
weitere Regionen unter Wasser seit
Beginn der Regenzeit starben 600
Menschen in den Fluten mehr als 1,3
Millionen mussten ihre Häuser verlassen
[Musik]
in Ludwigshafen in Rheinland-Pfalz sind
bei einem Messerangriff zwei Menschen
getötet worden der mutmaßliche Täter
nach Polizeiangaben ein 25-jähriger
Somalia soll zunächst vor einem Wohnhaus
einen 20 und einen 35 Jahre alten Mann
erstochen haben auf der Flucht habe er
dann in einem Drogeriemarkt einen
27-jährigen mit einem messerschwer
verletzt er Verdächtige wurde bei der
Festnahme angeschossen über die
Hintergründe der Tat ist noch nichts
bekannt
in Frankfurt hat ein Prozess gegen
Oberbürgermeister Feldmann von der SPD
begonnen es geht um Vorteilsannahme
konkret um einen hochdotierten Vertrag
für Feldmanns damalige Partnerin aber
der ob steht nicht nur juristisch unter
Druck rund um die Gewinn des
Europapokals von Eintracht Frankfurt
leistete sich Feldmann mehrere
Fehltritte danach folgte ein politisches
Gezerre fällt man bot sein Rückzug an
nahm das später aber wieder zurück
aktuell läuft ein abfallverfahren das
von fast allen Parteien mitgetragen wird
Peter Wagner
für Frankfurt zur B Peter Feldmann geht
es vor dem Landgericht ums ganze laut
Anklage soll er als Politiker Vorteile
angenommen und sich im Gegenzug
Wohlwollen gegenüber der
Arbeiterwohlfahrt verhalten haben einer
der Vorwürfe fällt man spätere Ehefrau
zu jeder habe als Leiterin einer
deutsch-türkischen AWO-Kita ohne
sachlichen Grund ab 2015 ein stark
überhöhtes Gehalt und einen Dienstwagen
bekommen die Staatsanwaltschaft zitiert
in der Anklage mehrfach aus
Kurznachrichten der awo-chefin wie
dieser stets konntest du dich auf unsere
Unterstützung und Loyalität verlassen
jetzt bauen wir auf dich und sieht darin
eine stillschweigende Übereinkunft fällt
man es Anwalt bestreitet dies auch die
Staatsanwaltschaft selbst geht nicht
davon aus dass sie ein entsprechenden
absoluten Beweis hätte sondern geht nur
davon aus dass es eine sogenannte
stillschweigende Vereinbarung gäbe wo
und wann die genau geschlossen worden
sei haben wir heute nicht gehört bei
korruptionsstraftaten es ist immer so
dass alle Beteiligten ein hohes
Interesse haben gemeinsam nicht
aufzufliegen das heißt solche
Einvernehmen zwischen jemandem der
Vorteile gibt und jemandem der Vorteile
nimmt werden in der Regel nicht irgendwo
schriftlich festgehalten sondern finden
in der Regel stillschweigend statt weil
man gerade keine Beweise schaffen will
das Korruptionsverfahren läuft bis Ende
November unabhängig vom Richterspruch
können Frankfurts Bürger ihr politisches
Urteil überfällt man in knapp drei
Wochen sprechen dann wird über seine
Abwahl abgestimmt
in Frankfurt ist die 74 Buchmesse
eröffnet worden es ist die erste seit
zwei Jahren ohne größere
corona-einschränkungen und doch ist
nicht alles beim Alten
insgesamt Feder Buchmarkt über alle
Vertriebswege hinweg in den ersten neun
Monaten dieses Jahres etwa zwei Prozent
zurück im Vergleich zum gleichen
Zeitraum vor Corona bei dem Buchhandlung
vor Ort sind es sogar 8,7% weniger
Umsatz eine Buchmesse in wirtschaftlich
und politisch unsicheren Zeiten Gastland
ist dieses Mal Spanien Isabel de la Vega
berichtet mit royalem Glanz eröffnet das
spanische Königspaar Philippe und
Leticia die Frankfurter Buchmesse
gemeinsam mit dem Bundespräsidenten ihre
Heimat ist ehrengastland der weltgrößten
Bücherschau der spanische Pavillon
präsentiert nicht nur viele neue Autoren
sondern auch über 400 Neuübersetzungen
ins Deutsche darunter starke
Frauenstimmen
wir Frauen waren ja doch als
Schriftstellerinnen in Spanien lange in
der Minderheit das ist jetzt anders es
gibt eine neue Generation von Autorinnen
die nun ins Licht der Öffentlichkeit
tritt
die Ukraine ist kriegsbedingt nur mit
einem kleinen Stand vertreten die großen
staatsnamen Verlage aus Russland wollte
man dieses Jahr nicht da haben wohl aber
werden russische Dissidenten auf der
Messe zu Bord kommen ein Thema das alle
beschäftigt die schwierige
wirtschaftliche Situation der Branche
die Energiekosten sind durch die Decke
der Logistikkosten sind durch die Decke
die Papierpreise sind durch die Decke
die Drucker haben keine Kapazität ja
weil sie alle für den Versand für den
Versand arbeiten und eigentlich gar
nicht mehr für den Buchdruck fünf Tage
lang dreht sich in Frankfurt alles ums
Buch ab Freitag ist die Messe fürs
Publikum geöffnet
und wir kommen zum Fußball Norbert und
zur zweiten Runde im DFB-Pokal und da
gibt es ja morgen eine besonders
interessante Partie Augsburg gegen
Bayern der FCA hatte ja dem FCB die
erste und bisher einzige Niederlage in
dieser Bundesliga-Saison beschert also
ein Duell das Spannung verspricht ein
Pokalfight als Bayern Revanche oder die
Fortführung der Augsburger Erfolgsserie
wir haben es jetzt zweimal geschafft zu
Hause
hintereinander Bayern zu besiegen warum
soll es nicht auch ein drittes Mal
gelingen Angstgegner Augsburg für die
Bayern das 1:0 hatte die damalige
Münchner Krise verschärft
das alles entscheidende dass wir gerade
gegen den Ball wenig zulassen sie weit
weg halten von unserem Tor nach den
Pokal bleibt den Kiel und Gladbach eine
neunte Bayern Niederlage wäre der
ko-hedrik in einer zweiten Runde ins
gegen pressing war sehr sehr gut von
Augsburg war unglaublich aktiv wir haben
wenig Zeit gehabt Lösung zu suchen nur
eins ist wirklich sicher einen rot mit
gewinnen
Augsburg gegen Bayern morgen Abend live
zu sehen bei uns im ZDF ab 20 Uhr und
die Tore und Höhepunkte der acht
pokalpartien vom heutigen Tag ja die
können sie später auch bei uns sehen auf
ZDF heute.de und in der ZDF heute App
Frankreichs Fußball Nationalspieler
Karim Benzema ist mit dem Ballon d'Or
ausgezeichnet worden der Stürmerstar vom
Champions League Sieger Real Madrid
gewann die prestigeträchtige Trophäe vor
Bayern Neuzugang sadio madé bei den
Frauen wurde die Spanierin Alexia
boutellias zur besten Spielerin gekürt
die deutschen Lena Oberdorf und
Alexandra Popp belegten die Plätze 4 und
zur Handball Club WM in Saudi-Arabien da
ist Titelverteidiger Magdeburg
erfolgreich gestartet der deutsche
Meister setzte sich gegen den
Außenseiter Sydney University souverän
mit 41 zu 23 durch bester Werfer Lukas
Meister mit sieben Treffern ja noch ein
weiterer Sieg und Magdeburg steht im
Halbfinale am Samstag
das war schon von Sport danke schön
Norbert wir gucken noch aufs Wetter denn
was das Wetter betrifft erwartet uns
morgen ein ruhiger Tag mehr dazu
erfahren Sie gleich von Christa Orden
Marietta Slomka begrüßt sie um 21.45 zum
heute-journal machen sie es gut
[Musik]
guten Abend diese Kaltfront sorgte in
der vergangenen Nacht und heute über der
Mitte Deutschlands für viele Wolken und
ordentlich Regen teils 30 bis 50 Liter
pro Quadratmeter jetzt kommt aus dem
Nordwesten aber ein Zwischenhoch und das
sorgt morgen für einen ruhigen und
trockenen Tag am Donnerstag greift dann
dieses Tief wieder auf uns über jetzt
heute Nacht haben wir aber erstmal die
letzten Schauer im Südosten die lassen
rasch nach dann ist es teils bewölkt
teils klar vor allem bildet sich gegen
Morgen in der Mitte und im Süden teils
dichter Nebel die Temperaturen sinken in
der Nacht auf 12 bis 4 Grad es ist dort
am kühlsten wo es am längsten aufklart
morgen steigen die Temperaturen dann
zwischen der Ostsee und dem Schwarzwald
auf 12 bis 20 Grad es ist kühler also
als heute trotzdem immer noch mild bis
sehr mild für diese Jahreszeit
Jahreszeiten typisch ist morgen
Vormittag aber eben vor allem in der
Mitte und im Süden der Nebel der sich
auch erst einmal noch hält nachmittags
erweitert ist dann mehr und mehr auf und
vor allem im Norden sieht man die Sonne
oft bei gleichem Temperaturniveau also
eher mild 12 bis 20 Grad geht es bis zum
Wochenende weiter am Donnerstag wird es
von Westen her aber unbeständiger und
dieses Schauer und kurzen Gewitter
ziehen dann erst am Samstag Richtung
Osten ab tschüss